У цю кімнату Ніхат Палантьокен
майже не входив з тих пір, як чотири місяці тому
його доньку вбили. Письмовий стіл, ліжко, дзеркало –
все залишилося, як було за її життя. Хелін мала
от-от розпочати навчання в університеті.
Я так радів, думаючи, що колись зможу
повісити її диплом в рамку. Але тепер
це вже неможливо.
17-річну дівчину застрелили в жовтні, коли вона
поверталася додому. Це зробив її знайомий,
з яким вона відмовилася зустрічатись.
Він застосував зброю – звичне явище в Туреччині.
Відтоді батько дівчини неодноразово звертався
до відповідних установ із закликом зробити
суворішим законодавство щодо володіння зброєю.
Я вимагаю щонайменше вилучити з обігу
велику кількість нелегальної зброї. Це врятує багато
людських життів. Тому що ця зброя здебільшого
перебуває на руках у душевнохворих та людей
з низькою освітою.
Ніхат Паландьокен швидко знаходить місце
вбивства його доньки. Сліди пострілів,
наче у зоні війни, вказують шлях убивці. Нападник
кілька разів стріляв у беззахисну жертву
з напівавтоматичної рушниці.  Вбивцю впіймали,
а от продавця нелегальної зброї відпустили.
Завтра і я можу наразитися на кулю, або хтось
інший, якщо так триватиме і далі. Цьому слід
покласти край. Я не побажаю комусь пережити те,
що довелось мені. Я втратив дитину.
Цього достатньо.
Жертви стрілянини в Туреччині є майже щодня.
Однокласники Хелін шоковані її вбивством, але
не особливо здивовані. Стати власником
вогнепальної зброї в Туреччині - не проблема.
Це дуже просто. Можна замовити
просто по інтернету і його доставлять прямо
до дверей. Неймовірно.
Продаж зброї через інтернет заборонений, але
але молодих дівчат та жінок це не дуже заспокоює,
адже саме вони переважно стають жертвами
збройних злочинів з боку чоловіків.
Авжеж, ми боїмося. Щодня це перехрестя нагадує
нам про небезпеку.
За оцінками експертів, у Туреччині -
20-25 мільйонів одиниць нелегальної вогнепальної зброї
на руках. Від неї гинуть у середньому п’ятеро людей
щодня – через вбивство, нещасні випадки або
самогубство. Протистояти цьому намагаються
активісти національної кампанії проти зброї.
Тим не менше, за минулий рік кількість
вогнепальної зброї в побуті зросла на
п’ять мільйонів одиниць.
Одна з причин у тому, що придбання ліцензії
на зброю дуже спростилося. Достатньо лише
довідки про несудимість та медичної довідки.
Ще один фактор - протягом останніх десяти років
рівень криміналу і політичної нестабільності в країні
зріс. І нарешті, сприяє поширенню зброї ще й те, що
штраф за нелегальне володіння зброєю
занадто малий.
Тим часом у продавців зброї - своя точка зору.
Фатіх Йандім вважає, що заборона зброї
не зменшить кількість жертв.
Варто зробити ще простішим легальне придбання
зброї. Тоді озброєння населення буде під контролем
країни і число жертв зменшиться. Адже злочинці
розумітимуть, що їх можуть швидко вичислити
за зареєстрованою зброєю.
Ніхат Палантьокен щодня відвідує кладовище,
де похована його старша донька. Одна з двох тисяч
жертв вогнепальної зброї за минулий рік.
Ніхат Палантьокен хоче продовжити боротьбу
за заборону зброї в Туреччині. Він вважає це
своїм боргом перед донькою.